there's one way to be rational there are
many ways to be irrational we could be
irrational by getting confused not
taking actions being myopic vindictive
emotional you name it there's lots of
ways to be wrong and because of that
there's not one way to fix it but one
interesting way to try and inject some
rationality is to think from an
outsider's perspective so here's what
happens when you think about your own
life you're trapped within your own
perspective you're trapped within your
own emotions and feelings and so on but
if you give advice to somebody else all
of a sudden you're not trapped within
that emotional combination mishmash
complexity and you can give advice that
is more forward-looking and not so
specific to the emotions so one idea is
to basically ask people for advice so if
you're falling in love with some some
person good advice is to go to your
mother and say mother what do you think
about the long-term compatibility of
that person you're infatuated right when
you infatuated you're not able to see
things three down three months down the
road you're saying I'm infatuated I'll
stay in fragile forever this will never
go away your mother being an outsider is
not infatuated and she could probably
look at things like long-term
compatibility and so on and but there's
other ways to do it which is not to be
advisors to other people but to be
advisors for ourselves so for example in
one experiment we asked people we said
look you went to your doctor they gave
you this diagnosis you know that the
thing that the doctor recommended is
much more expensive and there are other
things that would be much cheaper would
you go for a second opinion and people
say no my doctor recommended it how
could I not take their advice how could
I say can you please refer me for a
second opinion then we asked another
group we said here's the situation if
this happened to your friend
would you recommend that they go for a
second opinion
people said absolutely how could you not
go for a second opinion
so one idea is to try and get ourselves
from an outside perspective you look at
the situation
and then you say to yourself if this was
about somebody else somebody I love and
care about and then when this situation
what would why what would I advise them
and you would realize that often your
advice will be different and often a
more rational useful perspective
Oh
[Music]